sure
yeah I really don't know I know that you
know Comic Con has been a big popular
thing for a while and it seems like a
lot of filmmakers have attempted to do
this kind of thing but I think that it
takes someone with the talent of Morgan
Spurlock to be able to pull the entire
industry together to participate in this
kind of event and it's a lot of hard
work I think he was the guy that was
willing to put the time and hopefully
create a pretty awesome moving going to
do it
rat people that like my wife
Oh
sure sure no I mean I I think that it
takes hard work you know I will say that
you know it seems like I would be
thinner based on how much work I've done
but you know I would work 16 17 hours a
day just trying to get my name out there
and just try to get people to pay
attention to my comics and stuff and
I'll say that you know as far as getting
a TV show me like that such a complete
food like you might as well be asking me
how to get struck by lightning because I
have no idea how that happened and all I
can really do is enjoy it so it's it's a
guessing game it's like there's a lot of
chance involved but I can tell you right
now there's no chance of anything
happening if you're not willing to put
the hours in and really kind of just be
a slave to it and like it's been all
hours are all days trying to hone your
craft kissin but helps you know making
friends trying to you know worm your way
into different kinds of groups of people
that can help you out a you know in my
early days in comments I tried to get
get in touch with a bunch of publishers
and printers and just kind of learn the
ropes and you know get into that kind of
stuff and you know your friends can
always gonna be so be personable me I'm
not much I'm get yourself out there
right yeah it's all about relationships
you're trying to get sound to
relationships and heart spent hard work
and now I'm not making any sense so I
phone
no hang out the entire time we leave
your life yeah i don't know i mean i
think if somebody said that the george
clooney and they would have been
mistaken because i think it took him a
while to really catch on and now he's
you know one of the biggest stars in the
world but Amanda I don't know it's a
hard thing I think you either know when
to give up or you guys she was hiking
off if you're committed anything anyone
tells you is not really going to have a
sketch so if you're really committed to
being an actor being a director or
whatever and someone says you should
give it a tears you should give a chance
in five years we're not gonna listen to
you if you really commit and being
really committed is when you need
support with cancer it's a hard thing to
really say yeah it's hot
you